d'une perle à l'autre documentaire
réalisé par Hélène triggereau sans
grande partie tournée au sein du service
d'oncologie pédiatrique de l'hôpital
Morvan à Brest avec vous venez de les
entendre les témoignages souvent au
poignant d'enfants de soignants et de
parents qui chacun à leur place lutte
contre le cancer 500 enfants en meurent
chaque année en France et le nombre
d'enfants diagnostiqués malheureusement
ne baisse pas dès lors quels sont les
moyens scientifiques et sociaux à mettre
en oeuvre face au cancer pédiatrique
nous allons en débattre maintenant avec
nos invités présents sur ce plateau de
débat doc avec vous pour commencer Marie
Castet bienvenue à vous vous êtes
biologiste responsable de l'équipe Nord
cellulaire et cancer pédiatrique au
centre de recherche en cancérologie de
Lyon stéphane vedren est également avec
nous bienvenue à vous vous êtes
secrétaire et cofondateur de la
Fédération grandir sans cancer et co
fondateur de l'association et va pour la
vie Eva du nom de votre fille décédée en
2011 à la suite d'une tumeur du tronc
cérébrale et puis enfin avec nous
Béatrice Descamps bienvenue à vous vous
êtes député du Nord membre du groupe
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire et secrétaire de la
commission des affaires culturelles et
de l'éducation de l'Assemblée nationale
vous faites partie de ces parlementaires
qui depuis maintenant 2017 se sont
fortement appliqués sur cette question
il y a une raison précise pour laquelle
vous êtes impliqué sur cette question
est-ce que vous avez vous-même été
touché par le cancer parmi vos proches
d'un enfant alors raison précise je
pense qu'on ne peut qu'être sensible
à la maladie des enfants la maladie d'un
enfant en précisant votre métier c'est
institutrice voilà alors effectivement
lors de mes études pour être enseignante
d'ailleurs
j'ai j'ai l'occasion malheureusement de
devoir ma maman qui qui venait non pas
pour un cancer mais ne trouvez qu'une
place dans une chambre auprès d'un
enfant atteint de leucémie et c'était
enfant je l'ai suivi un peu après en
tant qu'enseignante à la demande des
parents il avait 4 ans mais ça lui
permettait de d'avoir un accompagnement
lorsqu'il est rentré chez lui autre
aussi que celui de ses parents donc la
vie le parcours de la vie qui vous a
fait vous intéresse au cours de la vie
effectivement qui m'ont fait mais comme
je le disais je pense qu'on ne peut
qu'être sensible à ces sujets et je
savais qu'en étant élu si je pouvais
travailler sur ces sujets je le ferai et
c'est ce que vous avez fait avec force
on va venir viendra d'ailleurs tout à
l'heure avec un certain d'autres de vos
collègues parlementaires d'ailleurs vous
êtes quelques-uns à l'Assemblée
nationale tout de même à lutter pour
notre sujet d'aujourd'hui Marie Castel
ce que ne savent peut-être pas ce qui
nous aujourd'hui ils l'ont appris grâce
à ce film c'est que les cancers
pédiatriques sont à distinguer des
autres types de concerts touchant les
adultes c'est bien cela oui
effectivement il y a 2500 enfants qui
sont touchés diagnostiqués chaque année
d'un cancer on a longtemps cru que il
suffirait en fait de chercher sur les
cancers de l'adulte qui sont beaucoup
plus fréquents que ceux de l'enfant pour
arriver à trouver des traitements et on
s'est rendu compte depuis une dizaine
d'années maintenant que ça n'était pas
le cas puisque les cancers de l'enfant
présente des spécificités des
spécificités apports de type de cancer
ils sont pas atteints des mêmes cancers
que ceux de l'adulte on a parlé des
tumeurs du tronc cérébral c'est aussi le
cas d'un certain nombre de tumeurs qu'on
appelle embryonnaire donc des
neuroblastomes des rétinoblastums ce
genre de cancer là et puis ils ont des
spécificités moléculaires c'est-à-dire
qu'ils n'ont pas par exemple le même
taux de mutation que les cancers de
l'adulte ils sont une composante
probablement développementale beaucoup
plus importante et donc il est
nécessaire de faire une recherche dédiée
sur ses cancers là il existe combien de
cancers pédiatrique aujourd'hui il y a
plus d'une soixantaine de types
différentes qui sont référencés à ce
jour mais en réalité il y a quasiment un
cancer par enfant puisqu'on sait
maintenant qu'il y a des spécificités
moléculaires pour chaque patient et
c'est cette complexité là qu'on doit
interroger nous en recherche et depuis
quand dans la communauté scientifique
est-ce qu'on distingue bel et bien les
cancers pédiatriques des autres alors il
y a très longtemps un distinguo de type
c'est à dire qu'on savait que les types
de cancers n'étaient pas les mêmes mais
on pensait qu'au niveau de la biologie
globalement c'était les mêmes mécanismes
qui étaient en jeu et donc en cherchant
chez les adultes on trouverait pour les
enfants on s'est rendu compte avec
l'avènement du séquençage c'est à dire
de la définition de la signature
moléculaire des cancers que ça n'est pas
le cas et qui a vraiment des
spécificités chez les enfants et qu'il
faut s'attaquer à ces spécificités pour
trouver des traitements qui soient à la
fois plus efficaces et moins toxiques on
va revenir à Eva décédé au bout de 7
mois et demi de maladie c'était en 2011
vous avez en tant que parents
qu'accompagnant au même titre que tous
ceux et celles qu'on a vu dans ce film
qui accompagne bien entendu leur enfant
qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus frappé
concernant le traitement de la maladie
qui concerne votre fille
la traduction que le corps médical vous
en a faite et peut-être les aides dont
vous avez bénéficié après le choc qui
est l'annonce d'un cancer d'un enfant
alors pour le traitement c'est très
simple il y en avait pas
on nous a annoncé en fait Eva a été
diagnostiqué suite à l'apparition d'un
très léger strabisme
n'a pas été concerné par un diagnostic
tardif puisque
en fait
on a eu un rendez-vous chez chez une
ophtalmo très rapidement l'ophtalmo a
très rapidement dit quelque chose qui
n'est pas normal à 7 ans et demi avoir
un strabisme ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
courant vous devez prendre rendez-vous
vous devez vous rendre aux urgences
faire une IRM immédiatement
étonnante on va dire donc on arrive on
se rend donc à l'hôpital de Bordeaux
et
là où nous annonce très rapidement après
avoir fait l'examen votre fille a une
masse une grosse masse
c'est une tumeur du troncérébrale terme
que j'ai découvert à l'époque bien sûr
c'est une opérable il n'y a rien à faire
elle en a si elle a pour 6 à 9 mois à
vivre je précise que ma fille était en
parfaite forme hormis ce strabisme mais
puis tout est allé finalement très vite
sachant que on parle souvent du
diagnostic précoce mais quand il n'y a
pas de traitement le diagnostic précoce
ne sert à rien puisque c'était le cas de
ma fille elle avait-il diagnostiqué très
rapidement et plutôt tôt finalement
dès l'apparition de du premier symptôme
en tout cas est-ce que vous a le plus
choqué il se trouve que nels Armstrong
celui qui a mis le premier le pied sur
la Lune il y a sa fille souffrait du
même cancer que Keva et ce qui vous fait
dire que depuis on a trouvé aucune
solution pour
résorber ce
ce qui vous fait dire que on ne fait
aucun progrès en la matière concernant
ce cancer ça c'est une première
chose qui a créé la colère chez vous oui
deuxième chose qui a pu créer la colère
est-ce que sont c'est l'entourage les
soignants ou alors les les aides dont
vous pouvez bénéficier en tant que
parents dont la fille avait un cancer
alors nous l'aider pour l'accompagner
tout simplement comme tous les parents
qu'on a vu dans ce film alors nous
notre priorité c'était de trouver une
solution pour guérir notre fille et on a
découvert à ce moment-là qu'il n'y avait
qu'il n'y avait rien on a découvert
aussi à ce moment là parce que les
questions qu'on se pose lorsqu'on n'est
parents et qu'on a un enfant qui est
touché par un cancer c'est pourquoi mon
enfant
et s'il n'y a pas de traitement pourquoi
pas de traitement ce sont les deux
questions en fait que l'on sait poser
pourquoi notre fille on ne sait toujours
pas
un enfant ça ne boit pas ça ne fume pas
ça ne se drogue pas ça
elle vivait en plus dans des conditions
elle respectait parfaitement je dirais
les préconisations des ministères de la
Santé du manger sain 5 fruits et légumes
par jour avec tes sportives
intellectuelle et donc on pourrait dire
pourquoi elle pas de avec un sentiment
d'injustice j'imagine le sentiment
d'injustice et double sentiment
d'injustice quand vous constatez après
derrière au fil des mois et même après
son décès qu'à l'époque à l'époque les
moyens alloués à la recherche sur les
cancers de l'enfant était dérisoire
parce que ça a été notre démarche de
fond je dirais après de se dire mais
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas de traitement
parce que on cherche mais on y arrive
pas les chercheurs ont tous les moyens
pour pour chercher mais il n'y arrive
pas ce qui est entendable ou est-ce que
il y a un problème de moyen on a
découvert en 2011 à l'époque que seul 2%
des fonds de recherche anti cancer
étaient alloués à l'enfant et que les
chercheurs souvent nous disaient on n'y
va pas parce que
c'est un problème et les industriels du
médicament n'y allez pas non plus à
cause d'un problème de rentabilité alors
ça on va revenir parce que c'est un
point sur lequel vous insistez beaucoup
oui
on vous a dit quelqu'un vous a dit il
n'y a pas de marché pour les enfants on
l'a souvent dit on vous l'a dit comme ça
et ça on y reviendra dans un instant
parce que je voudrais avoir votre avis
sur sur le sujet vous aussi vous avez
évidemment rencontrer des personnes
touchées par ce drame on va rappeler
tout de même que malheureusement entre
20 et 25% des enfants touchés par un
concerts vont néanmoins décéder au terme
de cette maladie alors on peut voir le
bouteille à moitié pleine aussi près de
80% des enfants peuvent se sortir d'un
cancer pédiat
quels sont les remarques qui vous
revenez avant vous saisissiez du
problème en tant que parlementaire quels
sont les échos les retours que vous
aviez justement du côté des soignants
des médecins et des parents bien entendu
qu'est-ce qui vous revenez le plus
souvent qu'est-ce qui n'allait pas je
vais vous répondre que c'est surtout du
côté des parents à l'époque je n'étais
pas élue je rencontrais de par de par ma
vie professionnelle surtout et par ma
vie locale
des parents confrontés
confrontés à cette maladie et
je pense que tu as raison Stéphane ce
que tu disais la première question
c'était mais pourquoi nous et pourquoi
ne peut-on faire pour essayer de guérir
nos enfants
et quand je vous disais tout à l'heure
que
impuissance médicale en l'occurrence
c'était plutôt ça la compréhension de ce
que vous allez vers vous c'est vraiment
cela dans un premier temps et on pouvait
l'entendre aussi bien sûr de la part de
du prof des professionnels de santé qui
qui eux aussi se sentent impuissants à
partir du moment où ils savent que
malheureusement pour certains cancers et
pour beaucoup de cancers de l'enfant et
ils ne peuvent
apporter de solutions aux parents et
doivent leur dire qu'aujourd'hui comme
comme toi tu l'as entendu il n'y a pas
de traitement donc c'est surtout ça et
c'est pour cela que une de mes premières
actions et en tout cas dans le groupe
dans lequel j'étais lorsque je suis
arrivée et déjà dès 2018 nous avons
regardé comment faire pour essayer
d'avoir davantage de moyens pour la
recherche parce que si ça n'avance pas
c'est parce qu'il manque moyen parce que
voilà c'est bien ce que nous ont montré
nos échanges après en tant que lui j'ai
beaucoup échangé avec des chercheurs
aussi avec des parents des associations
et c'est bien ce que nous entendions et
c'était c'est vrai que ça a été le mon
premier combat je dirais alors sur la
question des moyens on a un petit peu
avancé sur le plan
législatif on a un budget dédié à la
recherche sur les cancers pédiatriques
qui est de l'ordre de 5 millions d'euros
par an je crois et vous avez réussi à
obtenir c'est assez récent 20 millions
supplémentaires pour
pour évidemment de nouvelles recherches
j'imagine je ne sais pas dans quel
domaine on va vous le demander la
question des moyens vous en pâtisser
réellement vous trouvez que les choses
se sont améliorées depuis quelques
années depuis l'émergence de ces lois
notamment ici à l'Assemblée ce budget
spécifique dédié au cancer pédiatrique
les choses se sont améliorées c'est sûr
puisque effectivement le fait qu'il y a
un fléchage comme ça d'un budget qui
soit dédié au cancer de l'enfant
émerger des appels d'offres auxquelles
on peut répondre et qui sont vraiment
dédiés à la cancérologie pédiatrique
donc là c'est indéniable qui a eu qui a
eu une amélioration et après c'est vrai
que la recherche plus on a moyen plus on
se donne les chances de trouver ça veut
pas dire qu'on va trouver parce qu'il
faut aussi rester très humble la
recherche c'est quelque chose qui est
très compliqué les cancers de l'enfance
sont extrêmement compliqués il y a une
complexité intrinsèque sur les cancers
puisque ce sont des maladies qui ont la
capacité vraiment de qui sont très
dynamiques et qui sont très évolutives
dans le temps donc qui échappent en
permanence au traitement qu'on met en
place et en plus il y a une complexité
intrinsèque des cancers de l'enfant qui
est dû à la rareté des cas à l'échelle
de la recherche j'insiste à l'échelle de
la recherche qui fait que on est face à
cette double complexité donc les moyens
ne suffiront pas il va falloir aussi un
peu de génie et beaucoup de travail
collaboratifs mais en tout cas dans le
milieu médical parce que vous dites
qu'au début chacun travaillait un peu
dans son coin les choses ont l'air de
s'améliorer un tout petit peu avec
certaines plateformes d'échanges de
d'informations concernant les chercheurs
notamment ce qui est sûr c'est que en
fait au départ
il y avait pas vraiment d'activités en
fait si vous voulez la recherche elle
est divisée en trois pôles il y a la
recherche clinique qui est celle
vraiment qui consiste à tester des
nouveaux traitements sur les patients
qui celles qui est faite par les
médecins finalement et puis à l'autre
bout de la rouille à la recherche
fondamentale la recherche fondamentale
c'est celle qu'on conduit nous en
laboratoire en tant que chercheur et qui
vise vraiment à mieux comprendre la
biologie des tumeurs pourquoi est-ce
qu'elles arrivent dans un enfant jeune
qui n'est pas exposé à du tabac de
l'alcool à des facteurs de risque connus
et puis pourquoi est-ce que certains
enfants répondent au traitement et pas
d'autres voilà et donc tout ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle la recherche fondamentale
et puis entre les deux qui fait le
transfert il y a justement la recherche
translationnelle qui vise à partir de
ses connaissances faire de nouveaux
outils cliniques ce qui était vous dites
aussi que les ce budget ce fameux budget
qui est acquis cette fois
et fléchi quoi est-ce qu'on hiérarchise
les
cancers vers lesquels il faut il faut
porter l'effort en priorité comment les
choses s'organisent il a plutôt fléché
sur la recherche fondamentale et
translationnelle parce que justement ce
qui était très bien organisé en France
jusque là c'était la recherche clinique
il y avait des réseaux de médecins qui
existaient qui étaient même à l'échelle
européenne donc ça ça marchait très bien
en revanche il y avait un déficit de
recherche fondamentale et translationnel
et comme on s'est rendu compte qu'il y
avait des spécificités sur les cancers
de l'enfance et là-dessus qui a été mis
le budget j'ai lu quelque part et vous
nous l'avez laissez entendre tout à
l'heure vous dites
les industriels du médicament
il ne s'intéresse pratiquement pas au
cancer des enfants souvent comme
considéré par eux comme trop peu
rentable oui trop peu rentable alors ça
j'aimerais savoir
ce qu'il y a derrière ces propos
qu'est-ce qui vous fait dire cela le Big
Pharma n'investirait pas et la recherche
d'investirais pas suffisamment dans ces
cancers pédiatriques parce que ils ne
sont pas rentables parce qu'il y a pas
de marché c'est ce que vous avez entendu
moi je voudrais un peu plus qu'est-ce
qui vous fait dire ça aujourd'hui alors
en fait après le après le décès d'Eva
c'est vrai que outre le fait qu'on écrit
l'association évapore la vie les
premières actions ça a été donc comme je
disais de d'essayer de d'évaluer la
situation finalement d'une façon
objective la colère c'est une chose mais
après derrière il faut savoir pourquoi
on en est là est-ce que c'est l'une de
vos conclusions c'était celle-là la
conclusion est basée sur deux choses
c'est d'abord la force publique donc il
y a une insuffisance à l'époque au
niveau de la force publique qui a été
clairement
réduite depuis 2018
et puis le rôle des industriels du
médicament
et à partir de là on a mené un ensemble
d'enquêtes pour essayer d'évaluer quels
étaient leurs investissements on a
rencontré aussi des représentants du
même le même c'est le syndicat des
industriels de médicaments et donc la
conclusion c'est que l'immense majorité
des grands acteurs je parle des grands
acteurs des grands industriels de
médicaments ne s'investissaient pas sur
cette recherche ne financez pas cette
recherche de temps à autre ils vont
financer un poste ils vont financer même
des actions de confort parfois mais pour
le financement que ce soit de la
recherche fondamentale ou même
d'ailleurs des essais cliniques
la part la part des essais cliniques par
exemple qui sont financés par les
industriels du médicament et dérisoires
idem pour la recherche fondamentale et
c'est vrai que s'il y a une chose qui
n'a pas vraiment évolué parce qu'on a
beaucoup évolué en disant on a évolué
déjà parce qu'on en parle on est dans
cette émission on parle des cancers
pédiatriques et cela disant ça faisait
peur à tout le monde donc on a quand
même une évolution une évolution forte
au niveau des chercheurs qui se sont
qui sont coordonnées parce qu'il y avait
plus de moyens parce que forcément c'est
un moyen real focus c'est un réseau
auquel vous appartenez où effectivement
existe ces échanges c'est plateformes
d'échanges concernant oui les recherches
dont vous nous avez parlé tout à l'heure
notamment voilà exactement donc parce
que
avec des moyens on n'a pas la garantie
de réussir mais sans moyen on est sûr de
ne pas réussir et donc au niveau des
industriels médicaments on en est
toujours au même stade d'accord avec ce
constat et là qu'est-ce que peut faire
un législateur parce que évidemment il y
a pas de force pas de moyens de pression
là sur
l'élaboratoires pharmaceutiques et
effectivement on n'a pas on a ce constat
également alors on délaisserait on
oublierait les enfants concernant la
recherche dans ce domaine alors
rentabilité c'est possible c'est
possible pour échanger avec nombre de
personnes je peux dire que je l'entends
et que je peux le croire malheureusement
après je dis toujours vous savez quand
on est élu on n'est pas chercheur on
n'est pas médecin on n'est pas parents
qui avaient vécu qui ont vécu tel ou
telle chose mais c'est parce que l'on
écoute que l'on peut porter ces sujets
sont nécessaires de porter au niveau
national et ce que je me fais fort de
faire pas en écoutant une seule personne
pendant tout le temps un seul parent en
écoutant beaucoup de personnes qui vont
nous permettre de travailler pour faire
avancer les choses et aujourd'hui ce que
vient de décrire Stéphane oui je
l'entends je ne suis pas à même de juger
je le dis franchement mais parce que
j'écoute des personnes qui maîtrisent
les sujets je vais suivre ces personnes
quand je le juge nécessaire et c'est ce
que j'ai fait d'ailleurs à plusieurs
reprises parce que je pense que là c'est
ça mon rôle je ne veux pas prendre le
rôle je ne peux pas et je ne veux
surtout pas au contraire parce que je
pense que l'on se complète et on se
complète pour ses enfants pour qu'il
faut à qu'il faut apporter ses réponses
ces familles voilà qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous vous suivez ça de près tu
imagines que ce qu'on investit autant
dans les traitements contre les cancers
adultes que dans les traitements
forcément non parce que quand vous êtes
industriel du médicament et que vous
êtes avec des cancers du sein du côlon
du poumon où il y a des dizaines de
milliers de cas chaque année vous allez
pas avoir effectivement la même
possibilité de rentabilité qu'avec des
cancers qui touchent 50 60 enfants par
an c'est c'est évident ceci étant dit
j'ai tendance à voir que la situation
s'améliore un peu elle s'améliore parce
que je pense qu'il y a des industriels
qui qui comprennent qu'il y a un vrai en
jeu parce que il y a eu aussi une
organisation à l'échelle européenne qui
fait que on augmente du coup le nombre
de cas possibles
à inclure dans des essais par exemple et
puis aussi parce qu'en comprenant mieux
la biologie des cancers de l'enfant on
est en train de se rendre compte qu'on
peut peut-être aller dans l'autre sens
c'est-à-dire que jusque là on se disait
on va trouver un traitement chez les
adultes et puis on va l'essayer chez les
enfants là on est en train de se dire
bah il y a peut-être des choses qu'on va
trouver chez les enfants mais qu'on
pourra basculer chez les adultes et là
du coup effectivement la le nombre de
personnes à traiter n'est plus le même
et les industriels deviennent plus
intéressés et vous dites il faut réussir
à proposer des traitements plus ciblés
mieux adaptés afin d'éviter les
séquelles que l'on observe chez deux
tiers des patients de quel séquelles
parlons-nous pour commencer alors il y a
beaucoup de tirs des patients tout de
même c'est beaucoup de séquelles alors
on a coutume de parler beaucoup de du
problème de fert par exemple il y a les
chimiothérapies notamment qui qui
empêche ensuite les enfants d'avoir
eux-mêmes des enfants de devenir parents
mais il y a des soucis j'allais dire
presque plus grave en tout cas
biologiquement et médicalement avec des
problèmes cardiaques des risques de
cancer secondaire et ça c'est vrai que
c'est des choses qui vont suivre les
enfants de manière chronique tout au
long de leur vie et qui font du coup de
la cancérologie à un vrai problème de
santé publique parce qu'on peut dire oui
ok il y a que entre guillemets 2500
enfants qui sont touchés chaque année
mais c'est 2500 enfants ça va devenir de
1500 adultes qui vont eux souffrir de de
problèmes de santé majeur tout au long
de leur vie on va revoir un extrait si
vous voulez bien du documentaire il
s'agit de la mise à l'épreuve de la
famille après l'annonce de la maladie
c'est une grosse mise à l'épreuve pour
le couple pour une famille et une
famille qui peut en éclat facilement
avec
avec ce qu'on est en train de vivre
parce que
parce que ça nous pousse dans nos
retranchements
total c'est c'est
c'est on est on est à fleur de peau on
est on est
vraiment on sent que le moindre petite
étincelle ça peut partir existe-t-il une
épreuve plus plus dure plus longue que
d'être au chouette son enfant alors
avec un cancer vous en êtes passé par là
est-ce que vous avez été aidé
après l'annonce du concert de votre
fille vous-même bien sûr votre compagne
et comment alors dans notre cas on a eu
la chance de ne pas avoir besoin d'aide
personnellement puisqu'on avait plus de
crédit on n'avait pas de loyer et ma
propre activité chef d'entreprise me
permettait d'être aidé par une amie qui
m'a remplacé pendant les 9 mois les 7
mois exactement qui m'a remplacé
complètement bénévolement d'ailleurs et
ma femme était à son compte également à
cette époque et donc on avait une
certaine liberté je dirais dans notre
dans nos mouvements et on appuie pendant
ces 7 mois et demi
être avec Eva tout le temps sans rien
demander à l'État mais très clairement
on représente une toute petite minorité
de ces familles parce que l'immense
majorité des familles elles ont un
crédit elles ont loyers elles ont des
charges et la fratrie très souvent et va
être fille unique donc ça veut dire
qu'on n'avait pas cette cette difficulté
supplémentaire et ce qu'on a constaté
après le décédé va et même avant à vrai
dire en côtoyant des familles c'est que
beaucoup se retrouvaient face à une
double peine souvent à la à la maladie
de l'enfant se rajoutait la misère
sociale pourquoi parce que vous avez des
charges qui restent vous avez au moins
un des deux parents
et parfois il n'y a qu'un parent dans le
cas des familles qui qui doit arrêter de
travailler il n'y a pas le choix outre
le fait que on ne peut pas demander
décemment un parent qui est dans
l'enfant et touché par un cancer et
d'autant plus si on lui dit votre enfant
va mourir on ne peut pas décemment
demander à ses parents retourner
travailler c'est complètement impossible
et bien ses parents étaient confrontés
donc et sont confrontés à une baisse de
revenus
importante et donc les gros problèmes je
dirais qu'on pouvait constater et qu'on
peut constater encore aujourd'hui même
s'il y a eu des progrès ces derniers
temps c'est face
au logement d'une façon générale
logement la résidence principale pour
payer un loyer pour payer un crédit
voire même parfois aussi une
problématique qu'il faut penser pour
toutes les familles qui sont éloignées
de l'hôpital puisqu'il y a une trentaine
je pense de services oncologie
pédiatrique en France nous on était à
Bordeaux donc à proximité mais vous avez
des familles qui doivent parfois partir
à l'autre bout de la France parce qu'il
y a un essai clinique spécifique par
exemple à Gustave Roussy et ses familles
là comment elles font comment elles font
elles se retrouvent dans une situation
financière qui peut être vraiment
désastreuse et parfois au risque de
laisser tomber certains soins parce
qu'elles n'ont pas les moyens ça arrive
aussi alors vous dit-il eu des progrès
on va voir lesquels avec vous qu'est-ce
qui a été fait spécifiquement justement
pour ses parents alors sur ce sujet plus
particulièrement c'est relativement
récent on a on a travaillé sur sur la
recherche tout d'abord les moyens loués
à la recherche nous avons aussi
travaillé bon j'ai proposé qui a été
voté une PPL sur l'accompagnement des
enfants atteints de pathologies
chroniques dans laquelle bien sûr on
incluait les enfants atteints de cancer
la proposition de l'eau
mais pour répondre plus directement à
votre question
après effectivement tous ces sujets
le Conseil était là et je vais me
permettre de reprendre une parole d'une
maman qui m'a fortement marqué lors de
du colloque ici en février dernier une
maman qui avait elle-même a été atteinte
d'un cancer tant que jeune adulte donc
avec une activité professionnelle vous
allez comprendre pourquoi je vous dis ça
et qui malheureusement
quelques années après peu de temps après
elle devient maman pour son plus grand
bonheur et son enfant diagnostiqué peut
entrer avec un cancer et cette maman
nous a dit
ce que la société a fait pour moi en
tant qu'adulte parce que j'ai retrouvé
mon emploi j'ai retrouvé elle ne le fait
pas pour mon enfant c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui si je dois arrêter mon
travail pour mon enfant je n'ai pas
d'aide je l'avais en tant que
professionnel je l'ai pas en tant que
que maman et quand on entend ça et quand
on sait effectivement les difficultés
financières quand tu as ramené deux
parents ou le seul parent ça arrive
aussi se retrouve dans cette situation
de devoir arrêter ou limiter son
activité professionnelle alors c'est
vrai qu'il y a la JPP il y a des aides
financières qui peuvent être apportées
mais qui sont très limités et il faut
que ça aille au-delà de ça et nous
sommes à l'occasion journalière de
présence parentale pour les parents qui
une aide financière donc allouée par le
biais de la CAF aux parents qui doivent
limiter leur temps de travail mais il
fallait que ça au-delà de ça c'est ce
qu'a fait Paul Christophe et c'est ce
que j'ai fait aussi ensemble en tout cas
nous avons travaillé sur les sujets à
mes collègues députés dont la
proposition de loi vient d'être votée en
se penchant sur tous ces sujets dont tu
as parlé ben le logement éviter
l'expulsion tout simplement ça peut
paraître banal mais l'expulsion d'une
famille confrontée
vivant avec un enfant malade voilà tous
ces sujets là on essaie de les
travailler on les travaille le reste à
charge zéro aussi parce que quand les
parents sont en difficulté financière et
qu'en plus parce qu'ils ont des frais
occasionnés par la maladie de leur
enfant voilà ce sont des sujets qu'on a
apporté on travaille je travaille
actuellement aussi sur ces maisons qui
peuvent accueillir les enfants cette
problématique de la distance entre les
bon ça ne relève pas vraiment de la loi
donc on est en train de regarder avec
mon comment on peut essayer de trouver
des solutions pour que ils puissent
avoir davantage de maisons au moins une
par département par exemple voilà c'est
cette manière dont nous parlementaire
nous avons la possibilité de travailler
d'accompagner ces familles en moyenne le
traitement d'un cancer pédiatrique peut
durer combien de temps alors j'imagine
ça c'est vraiment ça dépend c'est très
variable si les plus long oui si les
premières lignes de traitement marche ça
peut être une année mais si elle ne
marche pas et qu'on rentre dans un cycle
on va avoir des deuxième ligne de
traitement des 3e ligne de traitement
parce qu'il y a des rechutes ça peut
s'étaler sur plusieurs années 5 ans 7
ans 10 ans parfois et c'est autant de
temps à passer auprès de son enfant pour
la présence est très important l'un des
parents on voit le seul parent en cas de
familles de monoparentale nous c'est
vrai que ce qu'on a fait avec
l'association au départ c'est qu'on est
des des familles
on s'est vite rendu compte qu'on était
dépassé finalement par les demandes et
c'est pour ça que quelque part le rôle
du parlementaire sur ce sujet là est
essentiel alors quand je parlais de
progrès je parlais de la location
journalière présence parentale qui a été
revalorisée mais justement sur
l'impulsion de Paul Christophe de de 900
euros au SMIC oui 1350 euros donc c'est
pas encore parfait mais c'est déjà quand
même mieux
il y avait une aberration aussi c'est
que elle était limitée à 300 jours sur 3
ans sur trois ans c'était un double
blocage comme ça et donc c'est passé à
620 jours donc c'est déjà c'est déjà
mieux par contre il faut savoir que ces
enfants sont souvent des handicaps et
vous avez une autre aide la location
d'éducation enfant handicapée et ses
aides là prennent en moyenne 6 à 9 mois
arrivé pour la JPP c'est encore trop
long c'est 3 à 4 mois et puis il y a le
risque de décrochement scolaire
vous y êtes j'imagine particulièrement
sensible en tant qu'enseigne
institutrice on a vu une jeune femme
témoigner qui avait été touché par la
maladie qui s'en sort mais qui qui
restera handicapé
pour quelques temps encore néanmoins la
dure doubler une année ça angoisse les
enfants s'angoisse les parents
est-ce qu'on a fait les progrès sur sur
ce plan particulierement de la scolarité
des enfants malades du cancer alors je
pense pas que l'on puisse parler de
progrès il y a encore des progrès à
faire effectivement moi je l'ai vécu
lorsque j'étais enseignante
le problème c'est ce sur le volontariat
donc déjà il faut
trouver des enseignants volontaires
proches de l'habitation moi je l'ai fait
dans mon école avec des enseignants de
l'école mais c'est parce qu'il y avait
des volontaires au sein de l'école ce
n'est pas toujours le cas ensuite la
durée d'aide possible et relativement
limité donc je pense qu'il y a vraiment
un travail à faire sur ce sujet c'est
vrai que c'est sans doute pas la
priorité pour les familles mais à un
moment donné que ce soit pour l'enfant
ou pour les familles je pense que c'est
important de se dire que l'enfant peut
continuer
à suivre cette scolarité qui serait
celle qui suivrait s'il ne vivait pas
malheureusement ce temps de maladie donc
je pense que voilà c'est ce sur quoi il
faut continuer à travailler il y a des
progrès à faire bon je crois qu'on peut
compter sur vous
grâce au travail parlementaire déjà
acquis et notamment grâce à vous et au
collègues parlementaires que vous avez
cité tout à l'heure merci vraiment à
tous les trois merci d'avoir participé à
cette émission dédiée donc au cancer
pédiatrique vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter merci
aussi à sel massali qui comme à la
coutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission et puis je vous donne
rendez-vous tout simplement pour un
prochain débat doc et ça sera bien
entendu avec son documentaire et son
débat à bientôt
[Musique]